[Music]  as usual toys will be the big driver for  seasonal spending adobe analytics is  predicting americans will shell out more  than 200 billion dollars online for the  holidays and the popular toys are  already going fast the interactive jj  doll  batman's new high-tech bat cave and well  if you can believe it or not pokemon  cards and the tamagotchi pets they're  popular once again during this 90s  renaissance but this holiday season  supply issues could leave stockings  empty if you don't move now  we've never seen anything like it on one  hand the toy industry is doing so well  on the other hand there's going to be  big challenges for the holiday season  so what's the advice from the experts if  you see a toy on the shelf that is on  your child's wish list right now  you better grab it because the next time  you're out and about with no more  shipments on the way it might be gone